Good morning everybody.
Jay Leno,
thank you very much for doing this man.
Thanks.
Thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.
Your your place is the most impressive thing that I've ever seen.
Someone on your garage.
I shouldn't say garage cause everybody thinks it's a garage.
You're Rod,
you have 12 garages,
12 giant warehouse buildings filled with the most amazing cars I've ever seen in
my entire life.
A couple amazing.
A lot of them are just the old cars that I like that are kind of fun.
I have a good story if guys got a good story about it.
I like how you tried to downplay it,
but I'm just telling you why.
Why is it as a fellow car nut you nearly of your proportion,
but I was blown away that that place is insane.
Well yeah,
your,
your videos up right now.
People love it.
It's almost a 200,000 hits so,
but thank you very much for having me.
I really appreciate it.
It was a lot of fun.
It was a,
it was really cool.
It was cool to be a passenger in my car and have you drive it around somebody
else beat the crap out of your car.
What's more fun than that?
How did you get started with such an insane collection?
Like what did you start out with?
And I used to work at car dealerships when I was a kid.
I worked at a Ford dealership.
I was in charge of the odometer.
Recalibrations that was my area really?
Well you know what?
You too back in the old days,
like a guy would bring your car in and had the boss would say,
I take it back and just turn back to this phenomenon.
Okay.
I met one guy came in with like a 64 Chevy and it had like 92,000 miles.
So he's making this deal for his new Ford,
you know,
Blah Ba ba and went back there with the drills,
spinning it back.
You know,
it's fun it with a drill.
So the guy comes out,
he goes that,
no,
give me my car back.
Cut Now.
Well,
that was cars going at 50,000 miles on it.
And he drove away and he went around the block and he came back with a big smile
on his face because he knew we had the dealership because he said,
and they gave him what he wanted because we had already turned the clock back so
you could have caught him and busted him like,
no,
no.
He's not like a federal crime known now.
It is not caught him.
I mean,
he could have caught you.
Yeah.
Back in the day that's used car dealers.
It was horrible.
It was terrible.
I was like,
I was a kid.
really?
This is what they do.
Okay.
Yeah.
What does the worst thing you ever saw them do?
Worst thing.
Well,
well,
you know,
you used to have stuff.
You want the undercoating.
Okay.
Tony Bells undercoating and they put the car in the rack and we take some black
paint.
Just spray underneath.
Just know like cheap black Rustoleum paint and then tell people as an
undercoating,
oh,
it's just,
yeah,
the carb.
This has really been cleaned up.
Like the scene from Fargo Copeland,
they charged him with it.
That's my favorite.
See what he's buying the car and went to the old couple and they're just yelling
at him.
A hilarious,
so you started off just working on cars,
working in dealerships and then somewhere along the line I started collecting
them.
Well I realize I'm never going to have any nice cars working at a car
dealership.
You know,
this only became a comedian.
So I became a comedian.
So I thought that seemed like a good way to make money at the time.
And it was,
yeah,
you're so in your element when you around cars and when you do that show,
it's so different.
And you know,
and,
and I said this with all due respect,
you are a great host of the tonight show.
You're a comic,
you know,
talking to like dopey celebrities.
Yeah.
I mean there are some really interesting ones,
but then there's like me,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
But then they're were like this really like reality stuff and people like,
you probably never saw that coming either when you first started hosting.
The tonight show,
there weren't reality stars.
They didn't exist.
Yeah,
that's true.
But you know,
I really enjoyed it cause I like people,
I like talking to people,
but a lot of times you don't really talk to the person.
You talked to the publicist.
I remember one time we had a this ice skater on I,
oh,
she's famous.
She was in the Olympics and then like 10 years old,
she was in playboy magazine.
Like she hadn't done anything for 10 years and she's in playboy.
So we've got a call from playboy.
Uh,
would you put so and so and okay.
Yeah,
she was America's sweetheart and now she's naked.
Okay.
That could be an interesting second guessed.
Okay,
fine.
So she comes in and her your tastes.
Mr [inaudible],
can I speak to you?
We are not mentioning the playboy article.
I go,
really?
Why don't you take your client and go home?
Okay.
I can get a comic here in four minutes.
This,
this is why your client is here.
You called us because you're naked in playboy.
Okay.
Hilarious.
We or will we are not mentioning what you're here for.
Right,
exactly.
Exactly.
I mean that,
that would happen all the time.
Just publicists would get mad because you,
yeah,
well the manipulation of the image,
it's really not that possible anymore because the internet kind of all comes
out.
You know,
it doesn't,
you know,
in the old days when you watch old shows with John and you see stars come out
and they would just make these horrible fashion mistakes,
so whatever,
cause they dress themselves or that now everybody has handlers.
You don't do this,
you don't do that.
Don't talk about the,
Oh no,
don't talk about that.
You know,
it's so it gets a little a,
it's not quite as loose as it used to be.
So you think that,
oh,
because of handlers and publicists and things along those lines,
everybody is,
is handled by somebody now or don't do this.
No,
don't kill.
Don't give your actual opinion on.
It's just say that we love everyone,
you know,
whatever it might be.
Did you ever think about going back to do a talk show on another network?
It never even occurred to me.
You know,
you can't make lightening strike twice.
When we did the tonight show,
we had a good crew,
I had a lot of stuff left over from Johnny in terms of um,
uh,
editing facilities,
all those kinds of stuff.
And when you try and recreate that again,
it costs you twice as much with half the budget.
I mean,
our sending hall is a good buddy of mine.
And when our scenario went to do his show again,
his hands were tied.
They gave him no budget,
you know,
I mean God bless him.
He made it work as best he could.
But like for example,
when a guest would come out from a TV show,
the band couldn't even play the theme song to the TV show because they didn't
have money for music rights.
So he just had to plan like porn music,
you know what I mean?
Just little things like that you don't even think about.
You know,
those are,
that's where the cost comes.
Get any music rights,
getting this,
getting that.
Uh,
so no,
I never thought about going to do it again.
I did it for 22 years,
you know,
it was number one when I got it was number one when I left.
That was perfect for me.
How many,
you know this,
you're in the fight came how many fighters?
They're tamp there champ.
The champ that come out of retirement,
they get their ass kicked.
You know,
you,
you can't make it strike twice.
Well with boxing and ends really bad with,
you know,
fighting a lot of times it ends really bad for a lot of the great ones.
It's the saddest thing in the world.
Functioning always ends bad.
Did you ever see requiem for a heavyweight?
Yeah,
we talked about in the video my all time favorite movie,
Anthony Quinn,
just the greatest actor.
And he goes in,
if you haven't seen this movie,
you got to get it because it's got Cassius clay in and not Muhammad Ali,
Cassius clay.
And,
and he plays mountain Rivera and he,
he was ranked fifth heavyweight in the world,
you know,
back in the 50s and movie takes place in the early sixties.
And he's still fighting.
And he goes for a job that an employment agency,
like it's a dishwasher and it's this heartbreaking when you go,
that was number five.
I was number five in the world and the woman looks at him like,
wow,
what?
Oh,
it's,
it's just a gut wrenching scene.
And you realize it's,
it must be awful to be in a profession where there's only one number one.
Like,
some people think you're funny.
Some people that got and funny,
some people use sex,
some people,
like I said,
fine.
It's all subjective.
There's only,
there's not one comedian and everybody else's ranked below.
It's one of you,
like,
you know,
uh,
but to be in a game like fighting where the,
where it's so,
uh,
what a wonderful,
oh hell,
I'll call you back later.
I'm doing a podcast.
Sorry.
Oh,
sorry about that.
I'd love to live TV.
Um,
uh,
it,
it must be tough to be in a field with,
cause that's it.
You're the only guy.
Yeah.
And your whole,
the whole purpose of it is to dish out destruction and someone's going to dish
it out to you.
And along the way you're taking some and before you know what your body just
doesn't function the same way.
And He,
my dad was a prize fighter.
That's what he did.
How did he retire?
Well,
I mean he eventually sold and she'll move.
And then the insurance company,
you know,
my dad grew up in,
in New York and during the depression and I never know how far my dad got in
school.
He'd never actually tell us,
you know,
but I know he quit and he became a prize fighter for awhile and then he became a
salesman cause he's pretty good with kids.
So we would always watch the fights together.
That was something my dad and I was did.
Wow.
Did he ever try to get you to do it?
Well,
yeah.
We played around a little bit with it,
but it was just not my,
I don't have that.
I don't have that killer instinct.
I don't hit the guy in the face and then I get in if you know,
it just,
it was,
it was not me.
It was not me.
I had a couple of fights when I was a teenager and it was like,
Oh man,
you know,
there's nothing like getting your ass kicked to put things in perspective.
You know,
most people have never had the crap beat out of them.
And when you've had that happen to you a couple of times,
you begin to appreciate the art of negotiation.
You know what I mean?
I,
the number of people I meet in this town,
they go,
let me tell you something.
If I ever see that guy,
I'm going to kick.
No,
you're not.
You're not going to kick his ass because look at you and look at him.
Okay.
He's a street guy.
You went to La d.
Dot.
College.
He just knows stuff.
You don't know.
It's not gonna happen,
but they have this,
they never had the crap kicked out of them,
so they just have this attitude that just makes me laugh.
Yeah.
I think it's healthy for every man to get punched in the face at least once in
his life.
Just to get humility a little bit.
I think you need to get knocked out.
I got knocked out a couple of times and I would see the cartoons where they see
stars and I'd go,
well,
that's kind of silly.
No,
you actually see stars.
I saw twinkling.
I saw twinkling things.
It's just like the cartoon.
I remember going down,
I was going,
Oh man,
this is just like the current dude when I hit the floor.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people,
especially in Hollywood that think that fighting is like a movie.
Like you could just piss to whip somebody.
Yeah.
That always drove me crazy.
We just whacked a guy over the head and they just,
they go out and they wake up in the head.
But other than that,
fine.
Well the funny thing about movies is whether you're the good bug,
good guy,
the bad guy,
the punches always thrown from the perspective of the person throwing the punch.
I've never seen a movie where the punch is coming at you.
You know what I mean?
So it's all is over the shoulder.
So as a viewer you're always throwing the punch.
That always makes,
I want to see a movie where the punches coming and hitting you in the face while
you're sitting there in the theater.
You don't really get that.
But yeah.
Well you can see the sparks and the w.
What happens when the punches hit your face and get the light show?
That's my favorite thing about these superhero movies.
You see the superhero,
he punches a car and the car fulls up like an accordion and then he punches the
other superhero and the guy goes,
oh,
oh man.
Yeah.
Well No,
I didn't.
His face get crushed like the card.
That's it.
I don't quite understand because it's a movie.
Jaylen moves.
Not Real life.
Exactly.
It just,
just a little escape.
Sort of like the tonight show.
You left on top like that.
That is rare that someone leaves.
Number one.
It usually they want to keep you around.
Everybody left the tonight show.
It was number one.
Steve on the left,
one is the number one Jack Paar left and it was number one.
Johnny left one.
It was number one I left was number one.
Do you miss it at all?
No.
You had your time.
You enjoyed it.
I love doing it.
You know this,
there's a point in your life where at my age I shouldn't have to know all the
Jaycees music.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I'm sorry.
I don't,
I can't pretend to know common and a con everybody's music.
I just don't,
it's,
you know,
knows how he brought up a lot of black guys that I grew up in the era of Paul
Simon and Marvin Gaye and all of those guests mall.
My,
it's more my era.
You know when you're 20 when you're 42 when you're talking to the 25 year old
super model.
Oh,
it's sexy.
When you 64 you don't like the creepy old guy.
Right,
right.
No thank you.
I'm sorry.
I mean it's true.
So where do you go to school?
You know,
I wasn't going to say to you,
okay,
I'm like 40 years older than you are.
What am I going to say to you?
You know,
so you just have to know when it's time to step aside,
but you are,
do your demeanor,
your what?
Your excitement level,
how natural is when you're doing your car show is very different and I think
people would,
I think there's two Jay Leno's,
there's the Jay Leno that host the tonight show,
which is a great entertainer.
You're a great interviewer,
but then there's you in your element when you're hosting Jay's garage.
I enjoyed being around show business as opposed to being immersed in it.
Like to me,
Charlie Sheen's a friend of mine,
I enjoy every time another hookup pushes want to Charlie's Mercedes off
Mulholland drive.
I get a kick out of it.
Like everybody,
I don't want to beat Charlie.
I don't want to live that life body by enjoy hearing about it and observing
Charlie when he comes to this show,
Charlie,
how you doing,
man Jay,
or whatever it might be.
So the tonight show was great that way.
I didn't have to actually be there.
I could be a part of it without being a part of it right now,
because it's not really,
I'm not really a party guy.
I'm not a drug guy.
I'm not an alcoholic guy,
you know?
It's just not what I do.
I enjoy observing it.
Whereas with cars,
it's what I really do.
Cars,
motorcycles.
I really just,
so I am immersed in that.
Whereas with show business,
I enjoy being around it.
You know,
probably the difference.
But you still do standup,
so you're still on the road all the time.
I love doing stand up.
That's the greatest.
But still you're still in showbizness.
Oh yeah,
I'm still in showbizness.
Yeah,
but you're not in that show.
But as the CEO,
it's like comics will think of standup as being very different than all the
other aspects of Showbiz.
Well,
it is different than all the other aspects of show business because it's the
only one where you don't need any other aspects of show business.
I mean,
I got started when I was in Boston.
I would go into bars with a $50 bill and I,
I would say I'm a comedian.
We don't hire comedians.
I ain't go look,
here's 50 bucks,
let me go on the state to tell some jobs.
If people leave,
you keep my 50 if I do,
oh,
can it get some last?
Give me my money back.
All right,
costs me about $300 he'll the long run.
But for the most part it was either,
yeah,
kid,
you were funny.
Here's your money back,
but you know,
don't we don't really do,
or oh,
that was okay.
Yeah,
come back Wednesday,
come back Wednesday.
We got to,
back then they had hootenanny nights.
It was folk singers stop you warm machine,
you know,
all those kinds of songs and,
and they put a comic on,
in between.
And that's the one thing about comedy.
You can take it and do it anywhere.
I mean,
we both know actors that are great that are funny,
but if a TV show gets canceled or the movies no good or the director,
yeah,
it's like they're at a work,
they can't go down to a bar and pass the hat and tell jokes or even negotiate a
salary.
It's,
you know,
so comedy is different because it's self sustaining hootenanny night.
Yeah.
That's what he used to call him boss,
nanny not,
yeah.
Yeah.
Wow.
So you really did that.
You would go,
was that your idea to put a $50 bill on the ballot?
Because that's,
you know,
I was lucky when I started,
I had never met another comic.
I didn't know anything about show business.
You're not going to know,
you know,
you know your Boston here from Ellen,
from Boston rather.
And I remember the neighbor lady saying to me,
you know,
you can't be a comedian.
I should find that was a comedian.
That's the way it is out there.
Unless you Fado is the comedian,
you can't,
you can't be one,
they won't let you do it,
you know?
And I thought,
well it doesn't make any sense.
So I used to just go around bars and places like that and in Boston and I
thought I was doing pretty good,
you know,
I really wasn't.
But to me I thought it was pretty good.
I got my start at a place called Lenny's on the turnpike and route one near
Saugus.
I know I used to play and he's all the time and Lenny made me kind of the house
comments and I got to work with miles Davis,
Mose Allison and all the great jazz artist.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's pretty cool.
That's where a giggles is and Sagas goes out there and a pizza place.
Princess Pizza.
Yeah,
I mean like Clark's joint makes me laugh.
Lenny Clark's brothers,
I love money.
Clark to the funniest guy.
He really,
and a true Boston comedian.
Yeah.
I never consider myself a Boston comedian because I was born in New York and I
moved to Boston and I was like 10 like my family moved there in [inaudible] 59
and we're still the new people I know people,
but Leno's they came here in 59.
You know the other people who have been there since [inaudible] 41 right,
exactly.
You know,
so they're,
you know,
they're the relatively new people.
Did you,
do they have open mic nights back then?
No,
there was no such thing as open mind.
This is before comedy clubs.
Comedy clubs didn't exhibit.
Did you start?
I started in 1969.
Wow.
And I used to work strip joints.
I used to work,
uh,
you know,
you remember the combat zone and bar.
I used to work all those strip joints.
I worked,
I remember I teamed up with two strippers,
literally pagan and I need a man that was her name and they were like 40 years
old and they were like,
they weren't prostitutes.
They were,
they were working class women,
Big Boston women with short hair that would wear wigs.
And like,
we would drive out to Fort Devins,
do a show for the soldiers,
they'd be there with drills and then,
you know,
power tools and they'd put,
and she put together this,
this,
uh,
what do you call that?
Clear plastic.
They have plexiglass,
plexiglass bathtub,
and she would take a bath,
you know,
like a stripper,
and so,
and,
and they were tough women and I was like 19 and they were like 40 and one day
we're out there doing a show and she's in the bath,
you know,
doing those kinds of stuff.
And I'm on stage just telling jokes.
That's so and so.
And some guy,
it's just Todd's heckling me.
And I remember she gets out of the bath tub,
walks over,
grabs the guy by neck,
punches him in the face,
breaks the guys,
knows the guy goes down,
the crowd is cheering,
she goes,
you need to catalog.
And then she gets back in the tub.
It's,
that's doing all the integration.
I mean,
it was hilarious.
It was hilarious.
It was a great,
it was a great time.
And they were really nice women.
They weren't hookers,
you know,
these are the women that back then being a typist or secretary,
that's really what was available to you as a woman if you were not a college
educated woman,
you know,
or a waitress or something like that.
So that's what they did.
They,
they had the car with their,
you know,
stripper and Cigna on the side.
I need a man and you know,
that kind of adult up picture of themselves painted on the fender and we just
drive around and,
and I would mc and introduced the girls and they would come out and do their
act,
you know,
but they're very protective of me cause I was like a kid.
Yeah,
it was,
it was really fun.
That's gotta be cool memory.
And I'm like,
that is so much more difficult than the standard sign up at the open mic night.
I started in 88.
It was just,
they had to have stitches,
whatever it open Mike night,
you go there,
you sign up and you know,
you'd get on three or four weeks.
How many boom is fairly new.
Um,
family knew.
I mean,
when I started,
I used to go to the,
I went to the Improv in New York in 69 and the Improv,
them bud blow was say,
okay for singers then you,
because it was all Broadway singers.
That's all the way.
There really wasn't a lot of people,
the one to be comedians because most comedians in the mid to late sixties were
middle aged Jewish guys.
Like Rodney Allan King a,
the first new young comics were like Robert Klein,
Richie prior,
uh,
George Carlin,
don't forget Richie prior we used to call him Richie.
I knew Richie,
Richie,
I've never heard him.
He say Richie prior,
you've got to remember in New York City up to about 66,
67,
uh,
you've got what they call a cabaret card,
which was the license.
You had a license to be an entertainer and if you use the full load of word on
stage,
a cop could come in,
pull your license,
tear it up.
You didn't work.
You could not work.
Lenny Bruce really helped break that because Lenny went to trial for,
you know,
for that.
That's what he,
that's what he was arrested for.
He's just doing his act.
You know,
he used to do a bit about,
uh,
if you don't like black women who,
who would you rather have sex with?
Lena Horne
or Kate Smith.
Well,
Kate Smith was an enormous woman at the time and it was a funny joke and oh,
that's solid.
That's a racist or that's whatever.
You can't do that.
And I remember a cop pulled his license and he went to court.
He eventually won and they did away with the whole cabaret license thing.
So most comedians were middle aged Jewish guys and talked about that.
The kids today with the long,
you know what,
I have so long to patch it to a damn tight to tell you that these kids,
they look like a Jack Deck,
like a jelly smelled like a John.
He's hippies.
I'll tell you.
And that was what it does.
What guys did,
nobody talks
stream of consciousness.
Nobody did what?
Uh,
what Richie and,
and,
and George Carlin.
I remember George when George was just a straight stand up and then he became
the hippy dippy weatherman.
And then he,
he had this radical change to the George Carlin we know now,
but he was,
the judge used to be in a comedy team actually.
Really with who?
With,
um,
ah,
I,
I'm,
it's the name just escapes me,
but uh,
I forgot.
But yeah,
I've seen some of his early,
early stuff.
It's fascinating to look at him because he was such,
such a different guy.
Yeah.
The fascinating one is also Rodney.
Cause before Rodney had the no respect Hook because Rodney was Jack Roy for
years.
Jack Roy,
he was,
that's his real name.
Uh,
Rodney worked,
uh,
and he couldn't make it and then he became an aluminum siding salesman.
Uh,
and then he came back at age 44 is Rodney Dangerfield.
Rodney had a muse by the name of Joe Answers.
Joe Ansys was one of those guys who was not a comedian himself,
cause he was too shy.
But it was really funny.
He was a guy.
All the Comedians love to hang out with because he would do table comedy.
You know,
you'd sit in there for four or five comics that it to canter's type place or a
Deli at two in the morning and he would just riff and all,
all the comics of just sit there with pens and pencils calmed me down because he
was so funny.
But he couldn't,
he couldn't physically bring himself to get on state.
He just couldn't do it.
And He,
I,
he was a guy that hell.
I remember Rodney,
uh,
used to do bits and when you hear one of his earlier,
he's got a funny one about being an airline pilot where he says,
uh,
this is Rodney's joke,
not mine.
I was like,
well,
he says,
Hey folks,
you're looking at them with her left side of the plane and you could see the
empire state building.
I look out the right side of the plane in New Jersey.
There you can see the remains of flight four 18,
which crashed in a fiery ball in that field over there.
Bob,
you are with me on that one.
Why?
You know,
and I met with that,
but all always used to make me laugh when he did that.
And then suddenly riding to became the hollow with the one line of guy.
But before that he was like a traditional comedic.
So how much time did he take off in between coming back?
It was like 10 years,
right?
Easy.
Yeah.
He raised the family.
What I knew was a good guy.
I don't know if he ever really quick,
I mean he quit hitting it hard.
He was selling the Loma signing and doing all that kind of stuff.
Having a group.
What a great story.
How about regular job?
That's why everybody uses aluminum siding is sort of the bad job because it's a
job Rodney had,
you know?
But yeah,
Rodney was a great story and I mean truly funny guy.
And the fact that he came back at 44 and just became an
icon.
Yeah.
As a,
it's really an amazing story.
Well,
sometimes you have to grow into your act.
You know,
when you're 19 or 20 and you're a fresh faced kid,
you don't look like the no respect.
You know,
Rodney needed to grow into that.
like I tell you,
you know what the,
you know what the hangdog look and the tie that's too tight and the cheap shirt
with buttons,
it looked like he choked to death.
I mean,
it was a great growing of the great comedy persona.
I used to work at great woods in Mansfield.
You know what,
that is a show.
Yeah.
I was a security guard out there and I got to see a lot of acts.
I can see Cosby out there and Kinison.
And,
uh,
when I was working,
I got,
I got to see Rodney,
and this was when,
when Rodney was in his complete,
not give a fuck state,
right.
Where he wore a bathrobe.
That's what he would go on stage with the bathroom.
So Rodney was backstage and,
uh,
you know,
I'm working in the backstage area and you get to see Rodney,
like there's,
the door was open to his dress room.
Rodney's hanging out back there,
walking around,
pacing slippers on bathrobe,
nothing on underneath it open.
Yeah,
I can give a fuck.
He's got a Dick like a horse.
Right.
And he's just allegedly,
I didn't see it,
but it was like,
I was like,
look at this guy.
Like this guy really knows it.
Like some people will pretend to not give a fuck.
This guy really didn't give a fuck.
His hair was all crazy and he would go on stage with the bathrobe and I couldn't
believe it.
I was 19 at the time.
Rod Rodney let me live in his,
uh,
it,
it danger fields and night club.
There was a storage closet in the back and I lived in there for a couple of
weeks.
Really?
Yeah.
They're just a cotton there and you,
you know,
with piles of Sangria,
whatever,
they got to sit and it just,
all the liquor and that's where I stay.
You lived in danger fields?
That's where I slept.
Slept,
wander the streets during the day.
But yeah.
Wow.
I worked at club a lot when I first moved to New York.
New York was an interest.
You know,
it's funny that when I was just getting started,
those were the last days of the old mob clubs.
They don't really have mob run joints anymore,
but those were really,
really scary.
I remember I worked a club once and the guy come up stage and then he said,
hey,
you're a funny kid.
And he put a hundred dollar bill in my pocket,
you know?
And I said,
oh,
well thank you.
So now I know I appreciate it as no,
please,
you know,
give it to the church or donation or something like that.
He goes,
no,
you can take it.
I said,
no,
I can't do that.
I really didn't earn it.
Thank you,
but please give it to maybe a waitress.
And then he said to me,
you know,
you're pretty smart.
You don't take money from people like me.
That's very smart.
Nobody's going to bother you.
I said,
okay,
thank you sir.
And I realized early on,
the guys that got in trouble with the guys that wanted to hang with the mob guys
and the mob guys,
hey,
do us a favor.
Deliver this package to the hotel.
We,
yeah,
sure.
Okay,
now they're screwed.
Now they're in.
I remember once years ago,
my wife,
why would I went to New York and I was working the Westchester premier theater
and there was a guy named Jimmy the weasel fratty.
You ever hear that name Jimmy?
The weasel was look great man.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so these two guys museum,
Mr Leno's,
Mr Lenos is on the,
you know,
this is raw code as well.
Okay.
And my wife was like,
oh,
these guys carry,
you know,
so that's the way.
So we're in the back of his Cadillac,
you know.
So I'm teasing my wife and I just kind of whispered her,
I didn't think the guys get him.
And I said,
you know,
and if I go into the city tonight,
I think I'm going to need a piece.
And this guy goes,
oh,
Mr Police,
he takes a gun out.
He throws it in the bag.
It was,
please take down one.
I said,
no,
I was looking at,
not please.
There's no numbers on it.
Just you don't need to do not the wooded when you're true.
Just Jordan,
the trash,
you know?
If you don't use it all,
you're just throw it away.
I said,
I don't really know.
Please.
I assist a,
okay,
thank you.
Now I got this gun and my wife was just like sweat bullets.
She's like,
we're where?
What have you got me to?
Where are we here?
What?
I mean,
it worked out okay,
but is it was just just funny.
You know,
just odd.
Well,
they ran Vegas.
They ran night clubs in New York.
Holly,
how did Al that die?
What happened?
Cooperations collaborations or mean or nasty or does it not?
Oh,
then,
oh wait,
wait,
wait.
At least a mob.
You got a free drink once in a while you got to go.
Did you lose the grant?
I me at the restaurant,
go,
whatever.
But no.
What's the corporations come in?
That was the end of that.
That'd be a bizarre time to come up.
It was really sad.
You know what's really funny?
It's like you always see
is on TV,
but when you're confronted by true psychopaths,
it is unbelievable.
You know,
I,
um,
well I told the story with Jerry one son,
his community and coffee,
but I didn't hear it.
Okay,
I get it.
I got a call one day from a Sinatra.
He says,
they,
Jane is sons of Italy dinner in Italy.
Can,
can you do it?
When is it,
he gives me the day and I said,
oh,
Mrs Sinatra,
Ahmet to holiday house in Pennsylvania with the sons of the pioneers.
That's what the,
Oh,
I said,
I'm opening for them on that day.
I'd love to do it for you,
but I can't do it.
Oh,
okay.
Thanks.
I said,
please send me a couple of hours later.
I get a call from Sinatra's agent,
uh,
hey,
we call it a holiday house.
They said they don't need you.
I don't need you all right.
Guess I'm going to Chicago.
So I go to Chicago and it's this Italian.
I'm not going to use any real names because if people are still around,
so it's doing this thing instead of golf course.
And they say to me,
listen to as a priest here,
so can you,
so keep your act,
you know,
glean anything.
I said,
okay,
fine.
So I got up when I do my little active find,
thank you.
Applause,
applause to sit down.
So this gangster guy gets up,
you know,
he goes on a welcome Y'alls to this,
uh,
you notice his place and wasn't going to say,
Oh shit,
I forgot.
I was going to say.
And when he said Shit,
the priest went
like this.
The guy goes,
wow,
hey fuck,
you got your 10 grand and a fucking bag.
It just goes crazy on his gut
and the place is just,
everybody's just,
just frozen with fear.
This guy,
he's just like crazy and the priest is like,
he's holding this bag with the 10 grand and you know,
and then he sits now son,
I'm sitting.
Then the guy come late,
Jay came in,
he goes,
let me ask you something.
You know,
stolen,
right?
I said,
why?
I don't know him that you rocky just come out.
This is 1976 that I said,
I don't know him.
I mean,
I met him,
you know,
we asked them to do this dinner is benefit today.
And he said No.
He said No.
And I said,
well,
I mean maybe he was busy.
He scratch screaming at me.
I go,
you're right.
I'm sure I'm fine.
He goes up,
he goes up,
this is,
come on,
let's play some golf.
Honestly,
I don't really play golf,
play golf.
He's an hour and golf carts and my point in this golf cart and we drive out to
about the 12th hole and we get to the 12th hole and there are these kind of 50
60 year old prostitutes,
topless with leopard skin print,
mini skirts,
handing out drinks.
It was like the craziest day of my life.
But this guy was like a true psycho criminal.
I mean just one of those guys like a scene from Goodfellas.
They're just killing it.
You know,
I always loved movies where somebody threatened someone like,
oh,
you're not going to kill me Bob,
cause I know you're not the kind of guy.
No,
no,
they will kill you.
They will kill you.
And they've just really made me laugh.
Is that guy still alive?
I he may still be alive.
Really?
Nah,
this is a while ago.
He's probably dead by now because he was an old guy then.
It seems like you're kind of like,
that's not going to make it.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you is,
and I know he made it through the teammates.
Wow.
It just hilarious.
You know,
so you don't really have those.
I'm sure you have to still have those guys,
but very,
very rarely.
They're not Italians anymore.
They've moved on to other ethnic Russian,
and that's how the ethnic group,
I'm not going to say anything.
Well,
there's always one,
one uh,
organized crime group that sort of dominates the market.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah,
it's,
it just,
it's just really odd.
It was just,
it was a fun time to be a comedian because you had to weave your way through for
the,
you know,
more amps.
Then the comic,
I heard his name.
Yeah.
He used to be on the,
on the Dick Van Dyke show I'm going to show.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well he got famous because he was Al Capone's favorite comedian.
Al Capone would always come in to see him.
Wow.
So Al would put him in Al like Al Capone would put him in his clubs.
And that's how Maury,
Maury really got famous because Al Capone loved him.
Thought he was hilarious.
You know?
But imagine if you don't make Al Capone laugh.
A lot of pressure.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
But he's like,
well we got,
we start on this.
Cause the comedy clubs,
there weren't comedy clubs.
There were just either jazz clubs.
See,
jazz clubs are great for Comedians because jazz audience is,
listen,
rock clubs were bad.
And during the late sixties comedy was kind of,
it wasn't,
it was the Vietnam War.
College kids were very serious.
You know,
everybody do those little place where the stage is dark and when you'd like to
flashlight and under your Chin,
stop your war machine click and they'd turn it off and then the guy would run to
another part of the stage.
Please stop your war machine clicking through.
You know,
it was all this conceptual kind of,
so comedy was really on the back burner.
It really took prior and Carlin,
Robert Klein and those guys to make it really pop again for young people.
What was it before that?
I mean when,
when were the first,
they say that Mark Twain was probably the first recognize standup comedian
because he used to do these monologues and readings of his war.
Oh sure,
sure.
And he would do them in front of a live audience.
People would laugh.
We don't stand up is like jazz.
It's a uniquely American art form.
Like when you go to England,
ups over there maybe come out in a dress and they sing a song to do a skit or
they do a little dance.
I mean now they have American style stand up.
But the idea of,
I always liked comics would look like normal people,
but were funny.
I was never a fan of the wacky props to the crazy hat.
Like Johnny Carson,
prior Cosby Kline Carlin's.
These guys look like regular guys you see on the street.
And then when they talked,
oh my God,
they were really,
really funny.
Those?
Is that something that really came later because most standup came out of
Vaudeville.
We had to,
that's what my mother used to say to me all the time when I got to,
I did.
You know,
no one wants someone that's funny all the time.
Why don't you just thinking a little song and then you'd do a little dance and
then you tell a joke.
I go,
okay,
mom.
That's great advice.
Thanks.
I really appreciate that.
That's what they used to do,
right?
Yeah.
That's what they used to do.
That's so bizarre.
It's so crazy that it happened in your lifetime.
I mean,
you went from doing those original clubs to being around,
you regularly work with a comedy and Magic Club,
which is like one of the biggest clubs in the country,
and I've been every Sunday since 78 and when you're not there,
I've been there.
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
I like it.
I liked that club because it's the best mainstream audience club.
You know,
the Hollywood clubs a great,
but it winds up being cliquey.
You're doing,
you know you're doing 20 minutes on a little shop on Melrose that may be a half
a dozen people know about and the audience is hysterical and the rest of the
world's going.
When you know you've got gotta,
you've got to have a broader appeal and when you go to the comedy Magic Club,
a lot of that audience is overnight is from the airport.
They missed the plane,
whatever,
the standard of local hotel,
oh,
let's go see what this is.
So you got people from all over the country.
Yeah,
it's a great place.
Anyway,
just Mike Lacey is just such an awesome guy.
He's a great guy.
He's probably the best club one of there is one of the best of all time.
He's just such a sweetheart.
Just they just,
it's like a trickles down from the top to the bottom.
All the people that work there.
It's an amazing spot.
But you were there for like the,
do you see the Mooney movie Lenny with Dustin Hoffman and planning Bruce when
he,
they show the early days of Lenny's comedy where he used to work with strippers
and all these different acts and then tell a few jokes and be like an MC
honey Harlow.
I think that he married his chipper.
You know,
it's interesting.
Dustin Hoffman's one of the greatest actors,
but I never bought that.
He was a stand up.
You know,
standup is so uniquely different from acting when people act like a stand up,
you know,
I'm anxious to see Mike apps now.
I heard it's going to play Richie prior.
It's be interesting to see because he's a comic,
so he understands how that works.
Actors tend to watch themselves when they're onstage.
By that I mean,
how do I look?
I hear noodle am I come in where it's comics just perform.
They don't really care if their face looks funny or whatever it is.
You a comic,
you just forming,
you know,
so an actors play comedians.
It never quite works for me as well as a comedian planet.
It can be done.
Well,
the worst example is the punchline with Tom Hanks and Sally fields.
That's,
I didn't see that one,
but I heard about it.
Don't know.
Save yourself.
It's one of those movies where you watch it.
You Go,
what the fuck am I looking at?
I'm looking at an optical illusion.
There's something behind the scenes here that's not really,
it's not,
they're not really doing standup,
but the people are laughing hard.
Yeah,
it it because it's hard to write jokes.
There's nothing harder than writing jokes.
That's what I hate about.
Cause whenever you watch a movie as a standup,
and I like a TV,
show it off.
So I said to him on Thursday and then the audience goes to layer.
It's not all right.
The whole joke.
Okay.
They always do that because it's hard.
It's hard writing Joe.
Not only that,
but a real comic is not going to want to write jokes for an actor.
Like if you have a good joke,
you're writing a good juggler.
I'm gonna keep this one for me.
Exactly.
Fucking shitty.
One of the Tom Hanks over here.
Exactly.
So you,
you saw the boom though in the 80s cause there was a big boom in the 80s.
I came along like I caught the crest.
I was,
I was there when,
when I started out people are like,
wow,
I should have started out in 84 84.
It was amazing.
I started in [inaudible] 88 and it was just like I,
in Boston in particular,
it was a pretty magical time.
It was a magical time.
Uh,
it was also,
you know,
to me you have a lot of people now that rush to the middle and then stay there
for 20 years and never quite get because you know,
I sound like an old guy here,
but when I started you had to work clean.
I mean it's really easy to take a clean joke and make it dirty.
It's almost impossible to take a really funny dirty joke and make it clean.
It just,
it doesn't work.
And when the punchline is some fall out of word,
what do you do with that?
What do you go with it?
You can't take it past a certain point if you're trying to get on television.
Well,
if you trying to get on television and you're trying to get any corporate work,
you this two Americas,
there really are.
There's one over here and one over here and if you can have a foot in both of
them,
you can do really well.
For example,
most corporate dates,
we'll pay you
10 weeks worth of comedy club salaries in one night if you can just work clean
and,
and by working clean,
I just mean no four letter words and you can talk politics,
you can do whatever you want,
but the number of comics that can't get past a certain point because they hit
that wall,
you know,
they rush right up to it and it's,
it's like horse power.
It's like being an athlete.
Plenty of guys can play football.
How many can get it past that certain,
you know,
the average athlete is what?
One in 10,000 and the average superstars,
what one and two or 300,000 and if you want to be that superstar,
you've got to work.
You've got to appeal to a more of a mass audience.
That's an interesting way of looking at it.
A lot of people would disagree and they would say that all they want to do is do
the best comedy or the best art that they can come up with.
And it's not necessarily something that a corporation is going to want a
highway.
I'm not saying but what,
no,
I think you're missing my point.
What I'm saying is what most people do is they want to play the audience where
they get the best laugh.
Okay.
I just go,
I just do colleges.
I just do hip little cool places.
You know,
I,
a couple of times I booked myself into oral Roberts University ones just to see
if I could play the Gig just as a challenge,
just as a challenge,
like setting up for a triathlon.
And it is,
it is.
And you know,
you know,
a perfect example of that was,
uh,
when Richie prior was getting ready to do is live in the sunset strip
movie.
Movio stand up.
I asked them could I follow Richie every single night and Richie would go up for
90 minutes,
just blow the room out at the comedy store.
I mean people falling down.
I mean it was the greatest thing we've ever seen.
And then I would go on and I realized at that point instead of having an hour's
worth of funding material,
I had about 18 minutes because I was following the greatest comic in the world.
And my good stuff was okay,
my okay stuff was in my,
and stuff was terrible.
But if you just play rooms where everybody laughs at everything you say,
you never get any better.
You know?
I remember Robin Williams once said to me,
he said,
I'm going to do some stuff tonight.
We watch it and okay.
And they laid that this was the height of Mork and Mindy Lane Gentlemen,
Robin Williams.
Oh,
the crowd.
And no matter what Robin said,
hilarious.
And Robin came off and he said any of that new stuff?
Funny?
I said,
Eh,
not really.
Well it wasn't,
it wasn't because they were reacting to Robin.
The phenomenon.
I mean,
obviously Robin could put a twist on it.
I'm not putting down Robin's a tuner and I'm just saying I know,
but he knew after listening to it,
which part of it really was funny,
what wasn't.
So the idea of eyeballs on one
of those people.
If you're a comic,
you should be able to play any type of audience.
If you're a fighter,
you should be able to fight anybody.
Right now,
I only flight tall,
skinny black guys.
No,
no,
no.
You should be able to play any kind of room.
So whenever I hear comics say,
well I don't do that,
or you know,
people are people,
you know that.
That's pretty much what it is.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's definitely like clicks in la live.
There's people that only like to do alternative rooms and you know,
which are much more accepting of very bland.
It's fine.
Hey,
I'm not putting it down.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But when you don't make it,
you can't blame it on,
well,
the IRS on people go,
this audience was really stupid.
No,
they're not.
They're not stupid.
You just didn't get your point across.
You know,
a lot of comedians want to impress an audience with how much they know now
itself.
They'll say,
ah,
the anthropomorphic tendencies.
You know,
why don't you just say you have a nice hot dogs are like,
people act like humans.
Okay,
now I know what you're talking about.
Okay.
If you don't know what anthropomorphic means,
the job's not going to work.
But you want to impress everybody how smart you are by throwing out
anthropomorphic.
You know,
comedians sometimes always have,
um,
an underlying thing they want to get some point across.
I remember a comedian was another,
the tonight show once and his opening line was,
you know,
I'm a Liberal Democrat and I said to him,
don't open.
Why,
don't just do the material.
We will figure out your politics within a minute and a half of your set.
But when you say to yourself,
here's what I am,
you've already lost half the crowd.
I mean,
I don't think most people could figure out my politics from the monologue
because I tried to humiliate and degrade everybody equally.
So one night,
oh,
I know you and your Republican friends,
well Linda,
you and your democratic buddies.
Oh,
hope you're happy what you said about Mr. Bush.
You know,
so that was the perfect thing when I got complaints on both sides.
What you were doing back then to buy by going to these different bars,
you kind of had to have a bulletproof act.
He kind of had to have an act that would work on virtually any kind of a club.
Yeah,
that's what you tried to do.
I mean,
it didn't always work.
I'm not making this all was worried,
but she kind of had to formulate something.
And the real trick was when you get famous somewhere,
get the hell out of there.
I mean,
I knew so many great comics in Boston that were really funny,
but their material was all about what happens in Boston.
And then they go to Connecticut or New York and it didn't work.
They don't,
it doesn't work.
So to me,
once I realized,
Oh,
I'm getting kind of a name for me here.
I've got to go someplace where nobody knows who I am.
And then I would go to the next place and start all over again.
That's amazing that you knew that though at the time you could feel it,
you know old view 2021 and you see it already figured that out.
When you're talking 21 you know this comics are inherently lazy.
They go to when the laughs,
I'm just gonna play that room.
You know I do better there.
They,
they know me.
They like my stuff there.
But why don't you go to the room where you suck?
Because
if you can get big laughs in the room where you suck right now,
you have two rooms you can go to.
Now you've got three.
I mean,
I saw the pride myself on being able to play any kind of Gig.
What's the Gig?
This Bible,
the only,
the only one that was really bad was I did a Christian farmers and I realized,
Oh my God,
things I wouldn't even thought the least bit objectionable were Gel.
Just horrible.
My rent.
Okay.
I'm like,
what do you remember?
Oh,
I,
yeah,
what was I talking to?
Just Christian farmers.
Yeah.
That was the audience,
you know,
it was just a,
I can't remember what the jokes were,
but just,
you know,
and he couldn't do a joke about masturbation,
anything,
you know,
just things that were normal everyday.
Now that was horrible that,
that one,
I misread it.
I notice in Boston when I started doing road gigs that I had all this great
material that I could use in town that was a local stuff about like say girls
from revere with their crazy hairdos curls from revere.
We're known for having these,
what we call bulletproof hair.
They would have fucking sprayed hair that was like a mile high.
It was like this crazy time in the 80s where they had these giant hairdos.
Yeah.
And I would,
it was a great bit in town and Boston.
I would do that bit.
It would kill,
I would go to Connecticut.
It would just die a vicious hall.
You're talking about this,
my best pitch ever worked at Beach Kolmar and over here?
No,
I never,
I don't think
just clothes.
I worked at place back in the early seventies.
And,
uh,
I remember the guy said to me,
hey,
when you come in,
don't worry your best clothes,
what?
It just don't wait your best clothes.
I go,
why?
I kind of forgot it.
So I,
I want my best clothes.
All right?
So I'm on stage and I realized that people in the front road,
they'd smoked the cigarettes down to the butt and then they flick an action,
you know?
So I'm on stage once and one lands on my shoulder,
you know,
and I don't see it,
but I hear as I'm setting the joke up,
I hear people laughing and I go,
oh,
I'm doing pretty good.
And I look up,
I look at my jackets on fire because this guy had flicked a cigarette,
it caught fire.
And then the guy said to me afterwards,
I told you about the way a good clothes.
I said,
Don,
right,
I'll do that next time.
It just made me laugh.
Jesus Christ.
So it was funny.
Joey Cole had told me he was doing pips in Brooklyn once.
And,
uh,
there was a guy that was sitting in the front row that kept telling them,
fuck you,
fuck,
I fucking hate you.
You're not funny.
And then you'd show him his gun that you lift up his shirt and show him his gun.
And then,
you know,
Joe,
you know Joey Cole,
it,
they know Joey.
I put Joe,
he's a sweetheart.
He's like,
hey,
how are,
Ya know,
he's like real like high energy,
real happy guy.
And this guy just showing him his gun and saying,
fuck you.
Oh yeah,
there's just things that you don't.
I had so many nights,
I had so many nightmare gigs.
One of my worst was a opening for Tom Jones for two every night in Vegas was two
weeks.
So I get there the army night and I walk out and there were 300 women or maybe
350 women in the Tom Jones fan club.
And they bought tickets to every show and they had assigned seats.
So I walk out the first night and then I see these 300 women in the first 10,
15 rows.
Uh,
there's a dinner show then.
So it wasn't,
it wasn't theater seating like,
no.
Okay.
I do my hack and I do.
Okay,
terrible.
Not real good.
Okay.
I got the second night and the same women are in the same seats and it,
I'm doing the same act.
I get nothing.
Okay.
By show nine it's like,
hey Mary,
hey sue,
how are you doing?
I go,
it's the same 300 women every single month.
And in their mind,
you see me being onstage is less time that Tom's doing right now.
They don't get,
the concept is an opening act,
but the most humiliating part was I come off stage and I'm like,
God,
this is awful.
And I walk out through the front and this girl goes,
hey,
great show.
I said,
oh,
thank you.
She looks at me like I said,
Thank you very much.
I said,
how are you good.
I see I'm to get a bite.
Sure.
Okay.
So I'm talking to this girl for a few minutes and she's,
I see she's getting a patient,
you know,
tapping.
She said,
look,
uh,
we going upstairs or what are not,
what?
Well,
I realized she was a hooker work in the room,
but she said,
good show.
I thought she'd seen the show.
She just said,
good show to anybody that walked out.
I said,
Oh,
you didn't see the shelf?
No.
Well you,
I said,
Oh,
I'm the guy.
you know,
I like what?
I'm like,
I don't want to buy a hooker.
I just like,
you're wasting my time.
And then she stomps out and that whole thing,
the whole coffee shop like a little,
the guy couldn't again.
How bad is that guy?
That hooker walked down on it,
so it's,
it's a horrible,
it's just,
what year was this?
Oh,
76 yeah.
I would love to go back in time to those days.
God,
I would love to go back just to see what it was like.
Well,
there wasn't really any different than now.
I mean,
you're on stage with a microphone.
It really wasn't
okay.
A whole lot different.
I mean,
the culture must have been so different.
The culture was different.
You know,
Freddy Prince was a good friend of mine.
Do you remember for any pants?
Right in front of,
used to stay with me when he worked the playboy Chico and the man,
when the men played the Playboy Club in Boston,
and they are the playboy.
He had to do six shows a night.
You had the penthouse in the playroom.
And I remember I had to,
there was a singer and I had,
I would open and then she would take her band to come upset and it would pass in
the hallway and she'd be carrying these drum sets because the musicians,
they don't have to move around and drove.
Singer has to move the drums and big sweat stains under her arms and she'd be in
tears by the fourth show.
She just looked like she'd been beat up.
But anyway,
Freddy's onstage and he's talking about Nixon and he said,
I think the joke he said that President Nixon,
whatever,
blah,
blah blah in this guy.
And you wanted to say,
you watch your mouth,
you know,
it's a Predator,
the United States.
And Fred,
uh,
what did he said?
Uh,
Nixon doesn't
something through something.
He sucks.
Well,
this guy takes out a gun.
That's fine.
It over Freddy's head,
you know,
he's a shooting into the car and the whole club just hits the ground,
just,
just crazy stuff that really doesn't happen a whole lot anymore.
Where was this?
What club was this?
Boston.
Wow.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Play fight clubs are actually great.
You know,
people may exist anymore.
They still do.
But you have no,
I give him credit.
He was the first guy.
No,
he was the first guy to let blacks walked through the front door,
that club and play in the club.
Get Gregory,
Louie Armstrong,
all these acts.
He treated them as equals,
which today you think was no,
in the old days,
black performance had to go in through the kitchen.
Half always.
You came in through the front door and you were treated with respect.
If anybody's said anything racial and got nature,
you've got thrown out of the club.
So he was really sort of a pioneer and being,
uh,
you know,
equality for performance.
So I always,
I mean I've done a million Hugh Hefner jokes is everybody has,
but um,
I always give him credit for that.
He was a,
he was really great that way.
Well,
he certainly,
he's always been on sort of the cutting edge socially.
I know certain scenes.
No,
no,
it just seems like it's kind of silly,
but yeah,
but back in the day,
well it's a hard gig to hold on to,
you know,
he was at the Disneyland recently and uh,
I was,
uh,
you know,
Disneyland,
they give you that VIP pass if you're a famous person,
you had to go through the exits.
Right,
right.
I didn't know about that back then.
And so he,
uh,
had gotten into the ride before,
you know,
he hadn't gotten to the line,
they just sort of walked him into the back door.
So all of a sudden he was there with like this captain's hat on with these two
girls that just had their,
their faces spray painted on.
And I was like,
this is the oddest thing that this guy does.
It's just so odd.
Yeah.
It does seem fun.
So old.
And yet he's still hanging around.
I'm like trying to piece it together for like the next hour.
Like does he enjoy this still or is this just like a publicity angle?
Okay.
Funny Story.
Back in [inaudible] 76,
uh,
Schwartzenegger and I get invited to have 25th anniversary party.
A comfortable mentioned drew and so arm,
like I knew Arnold and Arnold was enormous then he was like twice the size he is
that the hanging around.
And uh,
I have says to me,
Jerry,
would you like to have lunch with the girls with the girls?
I said,
sure,
that'd be great,
Ms Definition.
So I,
I go into this dining room and it's a beautiful mansion,
but it looks like a frat house.
You know,
it's all the wood is chipped in dented.
And when the parties,
there's a big long table,
no chairs,
about a half a dozen of the playboy bunnies hanging around,
you know,
in street clothes.
I was,
and this Butler guy walks in with the biggest bucket of Kentucky fried chicken
I'd ever seen it look like a trashcan.
You just puts it down and all the girls dive in and grab a piece of chicken.
I said,
really?
This is the
and playboy and lifestyle.
This is,
wow.
Pretty cool.
Just od a bucket of Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Like a garbage can full of feeds him like the way you would feed chickens.
Feed my own checkout serious.
I'll just put the food out and they all just,
there you go.
That's a,
that's a weird place.
They,
if you go by the grotto,
they still have the old phones.
Like the whole been there.
Yeah.
A buddy of mine went there.
This is like,
it sounds like an old joke,
but it's a funny story.
So he goes,
he's never been before and it's like really nervous.
So he's walking down by the grotto and he sees a couple of girls naked in the
pool.
So he hides behind a tree
and he's watching and he's watching them die.
He's watching him and he saw narrows.
He takes out a cigarette smoking
and security walks up,
grabs and goes,
hey,
no smoking.
Huh?
He just thought he'd get busted.
No,
he got busted for smoking.
It just made me laugh.
That is pretty funny.
Just so stupid.
The,
I was there for a,
I hosted him.
It was either marijuana policy project or normal,
I can't remember who a,
who had about,
I hosted this,
this,
uh,
event that they had there,
a fundraising event.
And it was just very strange to be around the grotto and just to,
to be in this place.
It just to think of all the things that have happened in that place out of odd,
you know,
you've got a lot of old guys,
guys,
guys my age now and girls are going,
oh look what James Francisco's gave me.
Oh,
it's a beautiful ring.
You know,
whatever it is.
Just some old movie star from the 80s you know,
hilarious.
Just hanging on,
trying their best.
Well,
if you're still in the game,
every now and then a pitch comes your way that you can,
right?
That's right.
Low hanging fruit.
So when you're in your day,
when you,
when you started out doing these strange clubs and you know,
Hootenanny's and all and all that jazz,
how long was it before the comedy club came around?
How was that?
How was that received?
Comedy Club came around the beginning of the eighties.
Um,
probably
so like right when I,
I started in 88 so when they were talking about like 84,
that was really when it kind of really started out with
the peak and then it then,
cause you know,
the comedy clubs in the 80s probably paid more money than they do now.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And then they realized,
they realized,
oh,
there's a million comics,
we don't have to pay these guys anything.
And then the price went way down by the bay.
50% dropped way,
way off because in the early days there weren't that many comedians and really
weren't when I was,
when I,
uh,
went to New York,
go to the Improv,
there may be three comedians and like 10 singers on the audition night.
Now everybody wants to be a comedian.
But by then,
back then it really was not what it is now.
What was it about comedy that just drew you to it?
Because it seems like that is not an path.
Back then it seemed like there's no direct route.
Like,
now you can go to the comedy store,
you sign up for potluck night and you know,
if you go enough nights in a row,
you're eventually going to get on stage.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
for me,
I was dyslexic as a kid,
so I really wasn't good at anything except just talking and bullshitting or
whatever it might be.
And I,
you know,
I,
I used to like to watch comedians on TV and I thought,
well this might be a fun thing to try and do.
And that's pretty much what I did.
I mean,
when I got started,
I went to Emerson College and I took a course and I took speech courses cause
you had to give a talk at the end.
And what I used to do was I would memorize like a George Carlin routine.
I would never say it out loud.
I would memorize it in my head.
I would say,
okay,
I'm going to go on a few minutes.
And I would do his routine.
And then as soon as they hit the stage,
I would slip into my own experiences.
Like,
I remember he,
uh,
he had the class,
he had the class clown album.
So I would recite his jokes.
And then when I hit the stage,
I would say,
you know what,
I always a kid.
I was also a class clown.
And then I would,
I would tell funny stories or whatever it was about mine,
but I used his rhythm as the infant is to get me into it.
I mean,
I never did any of George's material,
but it just worked for me as a way to,
it's kind of a,
uh,
you know,
we can get you started.
Yeah.
It's like when he married a long time,
you watch porn first.
You know,
when I was,
uh,
working at Boston Globe,
I used to deliver the globe.
And,
uh,
I would,
go to the places where I would pick up the papers.
And there was a bunch of guys,
it was guy named,
uh,
God,
I forget his name was an Indian gentleman who was actually a pharmacologist in
India.
Right.
Get a license for it in America.
So he's working as a,
as a paper guy at the Boston Globe were really bright guy.
Right.
And uh,
you know,
he would talk to me about American culture and stuff like that.
And I asked him,
you ever heard of Sam Kinison how's obsessed with Candice?
And back then,
this is like 86 before ever started doing comedy.
And uh,
I would,
I would do like a Kennison bit for him.
And uh,
he was crying.
I was doing a bit about Sam Kinison at a bit about dog psychologists know.
He goes,
ah,
he goes,
I'd like to get in on some of that money.
He goes,
yeah,
what are you having a problem with sparky?
Yeah.
Spark.
He's not a,
he's not acting himself.
Oh,
I'll take care of it.
And it takes him into the Fred's of all,
you're a fucking dog.
Oh.
Yet,
you know,
he was a funny person.
Horrible guy.
Yeah.
He's mean nasty guy.
Seems like it.
And near the end,
he was pulling guns on people and well,
there was a youth
be a bullet hole at the comedy store and the belly room sign that for whatever
reason,
some asshole decided to repair.
I was so fucking mad and I hadn't been there in seven years and I came back and
the,
the sign was fixed like a,
what did you do?
What did you do?
That wasn't bad.
It was history.
I can't remember if I was,
I,
I'm not sure if I put him on the tonight show first.
He was how I was guest hosting and I had Sam on a one time,
um,
he might've been on before that I'm not,
I can't,
I,
so I'm not going to try and take credit for that.
But you know,
he was truly funny,
but just really dark.
I mean,
just nasty.
we're just like how sal,
um,
young comic in the hall back just rip them.
I mean,
way crueler than it needed to be.
I mean it was,
and he was brilliant,
you know,
but it's like when Sam died,
it was like,
that's almost how he had to go out because he was so,
like,
he had that hilarious bit about necrophilia and then one,
nothing funnier.
Yeah.
Okay,
so what's your next bit?
Okay.
If you have a thing about scoring dead people,
what is,
what's more outrageous than this?
I know,
right?
You know,
he kept trying to top himself and is able to do it,
you know?
Uh,
but it just got so crazy and then it's that thing where you start believing your
own publicity instead of just showing up as a comic.
You're not have an entourage and everything you say is funny,
you can't,
you know,
is a calming perspective.
Yeah.
You've got to be able to say to people,
is this really funny?
And you know,
no,
it's not that good,
man.
Okay,
thanks.
Like why does,
and about Robin,
you had to be able to,
to ask people that question.
That's why Steve Martin Quinn,
Steve Martin,
yeah.
When he talked about in his book that he's just got to a point where just
everything he said was funny and it just,
he knew it was wrong.
He was a great guy.
Steve is the one that brought Johnny and to see me at the time.
Really?
Yeah.
And I was always very grateful for that.
You know,
I love Steve Martin.
Oh,
he's a great guy,
great guy and,
and uh,
intelligent guy,
thoughtful guy.
Um,
really looks at it analytically from an artist's perspective.
He's really,
you know,
he's one of those guys,
like I said,
like Johnny who looks like a normal person,
but they just think unusual and think funny.
Kennison is my favorite example that I use to young comics when I talk about
like,
you got to stay the course.
Like you can't,
like once you make it,
it's even more hard because once you make it,
then people require things of you and you have to look at yourself as
objectively and analytically as you,
you look at the whole world.
Kennison was brilliant in my opinion.
He was like one of the best ever,
if not the best ever in 1986 and then by 1989 he was a fucking shell of himself
and was barely acceptable.
It was that case of all comics like to have some sort of open wound,
alcoholic drug addict too straight to gay to something so they have an excuse
when it doesn't get a laugh.
Hey,
I did pretty good considering I was stoned and it was pretty funny cause I was
drinking all day before we went on to say they always need a reason why it
didn't work if it didn't work.
And so consequently you get to that point where that crutch gets bigger and
bigger and bigger.
You know,
the idea is
to try and put that stuff aside.
It's a lot of discipline.
Being a comic,
you really have to,
you can't believe your own publicity.
See I'm a huge believer in low self esteem.
I think it's because when you have low self esteem,
you don't imagine automatically think you have the smartest one in the room.
You know,
you just shut up and maybe listen and take some advice and whatever and work
harder.
But you know,
actors and criminals,
there's high self esteem and the long haul,
the
true,
every criminal will tell you,
you know,
something that the cops hadn't come,
that would have been the greatest robber.
You know,
they all have a reason why there's a,
it's always somebody else's fault,
you know?
And that's the thing Sam had that Sam,
you worked at the crutch got bigger and bigger and he's,
he got funnier and funnier.
You needed more drugs and more whatever to two because all that's,
that's why the third showed in work man.
Cause I was so high.
Oh okay.
It wasn't Sam's fault,
he was too high,
you know?
Does that make any sense to,
you know,
it does.
And I also think he was so caught up in partying that he never really sat down
and wrote anymore.
Well again,
that's the same,
we're saying the same,
call it partying,
call it whatever you want.
You know,
the real trick to being a comedian is,
is it's,
it's focused.
It's a genetic flaw that makes you a comedian.
It's not nothing,
right?
It's not a plus.
It's a negative.
I mean,
if you happen to live in the time of the Crusades,
who's a soldier?
Megan,
all the men left,
kill him.
All right?
You know,
we just happen to live in a time when comedy is advantageous,
but if you're a soldier and this guy is hysterical and men are all laughing and
then I pick it,
kill that guy,
boom,
they kill it.
There you go.
Simple as that.
Or You'd be the gesture for the king until he decided to cut your head off and
further.
There's a pressure gauge right there.
No,
but see that that was,
you know,
I remember years ago when I started the tonight show,
there were other guests hosts on opposite me,
not guess what other shows.
And I remember,
and I go home every night and I'd write,
and I remember one time I turned on the news and I saw one of the hosts at a
Laker game.
I'm like,
Oh,
you're not going to have a monologue tomorrow night.
I know he's not because I'm writing jokes and he's been at the Laker game all
night and when I watched his monologue and the next night,
the person didn't have any material.
I mean he got through it,
but it,
it wasn't Chris,
but wasn't sharp.
You know,
you'd have to focus that discipline is really,
it's ironic in a way because what makes you a comic in the first place?
Usually?
Cause you're fucked off in school and you were the class clown.
You didn't have any discipline.
That was me.
Yeah.
I was meeting to Jay has the ability but does not apply himself.
Exactly.
Verbatim.
I bet you can go across the board,
Richard,
Jenny,
you know Dave Shabbat every fucking comic.
Then we'd have the same thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
I remember my mother was called into school once with the guidance counselor and
I'm sitting there,
the guidance counselors and my mother.
Have you ever thought of taking Jay at a school?
My Mom said,
why?
And he said,
well,
you know,
education is not for everyone.
I'm going,
hello,
I'm in the room because we'll show you worked at Mcdonald's after school,
right?
Well,
they have an excellent program with that Mcdonnell University.
You learn to make change and run the register.
I go,
no,
you know I'm not,
I'm not that bad.
You know,
Jesus Christ,
hilarious.
Teachers don't,
I don't know if they understand or they don't understand,
but when you set an example like that for a kid,
you put it in front of them like that.
They're not going to,
they should drop off and take a trade or something like that.
Actually,
I credit one of my teachers,
Mrs Hawks,
I had just teach her and she pulled me aside one day and she said,
you know,
you're not a very good student,
but I see you in class.
I see you in the hallway and you see it'd be telling jokes and people.
She says,
why don't you write some of these stories down and I'll give you credit English
class and you can read them to the class.
And I said,
oh,
it was the first time my life,
I really enjoyed doing a homework.
I went out and I wrote the story out and that's it.
And they change the line.
They rewrote it and I realized I'd spent like two hours work on the homework
assignment.
I normally would just spend 10 minutes on.
And when I went to school in the next day and I read it,
I want it got laughs.
She said,
okay,
I'll give you a credit.
I'll give you a knife for that.
I went,
oh,
thank,
I mean this was a teacher taking something I could use in the real world.
You know,
I'm not,
I'm dyslexic,
I'm not going to use Algebra.
I'm never gonna use Algebra.
But this teacher saw something where she said,
okay,
and you know,
I set up a scholarship for her and I,
and she passed away fairly young breast cancer.
But um,
it was,
it was just great because I had never really thought about,
you know,
you grew up in Andover,
Massachusetts.
I'm thinking about being a kid and you think about working in the factory or
something.
And I thought,
oh,
it was the first time in my life I had used comedy and it got me something.
I got an a.
I know I never got a day,
but I got an a on this paper,
you know.
Oh,
okay.
So then I,
that's how I started.
That's really what got me going.
I used to draw cartoons.
That's how I got into it.
I used to draw cartoons and my teacher's like doing sex acts with other students
like pet or see now you'd be sent to prison.
Like visual.
I didn't show like genitals,
but you know,
I showed like I was in Boise,
we went to boy scout camp when I was kid and I think it was camp on way in New
Hampshire.
I went to camp in New Hampshire as a boy scout.
Okay.
Well we had a camp counselor,
Mr. Butler,
I think his name was,
and this is like cub scouts.
It's like nine 10 11 and if you did something wrong for punishment,
you had to stack rocks and build the wall in front of Mr Butlins cabin nude.
Okay.
Oh Geez.
We go by him.
He laughed.
I looked at Billy,
cause when you know,
when you're nine and 10 you just,
you don't realize though is getting married.
I don't think that ever happened,
but it was mostly,
and,
and Mr. Butler would sit there with his pipe and just kind of sit in the rocking
chair and you know,
it was probably Christ.
It's probably eight years later,
I'm on like route for 95 going through Worcester.
Oh wait a minute.
I mean it never occurred to me because you know,
when you're a kid is just skinny dipping all that.
You're not thinking anything like that.
It just,
yeah.
So it never occurred to you that Mr. Butler is probably a pervert.
No,
no.
But once you got older you realized,
Oh yeah,
you meet a few perverts.
You Go,
this is not a normal punishment,
sir.
I rest my case.
What was about Kennison that was so mean.
Like what was it when you saying he's just a nasty person?
I know,
you know Carla Bows,
a friend of mine,
he must have some stories.
Oh,
he's got a horrible story.
Child turned out to be kinisons child.
Kennison was banging his best friend's wife behind his back and it's,
it's terrible.
I mean,
and I don't know what is relationship like is like with the child,
you need any other stories,
you know?
I mean,
it's not the child's fault.
It's,
I would like to think that I would be man enough to recognize it's not the
child's fault and not punish the child for it and just still treat the child
like it's my child,
especially since Kennison is dead,
but he,
you know,
he had been paying alimony and child support for this for the longest time and
it's just what a betrayal to this friend.
Okay.
Well,
there you answered your own question.
What's the next question?
Yeah,
that's not good.
Yeah.
But I had heard that they did some wife swapping and shit back then too.
I Dunno about that complicated.
I just knew it was just kind of a nasty,
just me is,
it's interesting because that,
that guy just sort of changed what comedy was for a little bit.
Good.
It was an,
it was a truly unique style.
Nobody else had worked like that ever.
I mean,
just as Rodney had a style and Robin had a style,
a Kennison had a style.
No one has had come along before or since.
Really with that energy that drains to it to,
it was an anger.
Obviously they came from,
I don't know whether abuse or religious and tolerance,
whatever it was when he was a kid.
But did you ever read his brother's book?
My brother Sam?
No,
I didn't read the book or the bill wrote a book and it's a really good book and
it's really objective.
It's really,
it's not like a fluff piece.
And he said that Sam got hit by,
I think it was a car,
a truck when he was young boy and it was never the same again.
And head injuries oftentimes lead to like very impulsive,
radically different behavior.
That would certainly be the case there.
Yeah.
I mean he was impulsive and in radical,
you know,
but like you say,
it's,
it's a,
it's a bit like that animal with a horn grows out and eventually curves and
grows back into its own head and it goes crazy.
I mean that's Kinda like what Sam was,
I mean like 84 85 86 nothing bigger by the early nineties.
It was uh,
it was pretty,
it was,
I got to see me live after his HBO special,
like almost immediately after and he didn't really have material.
Right.
He like,
he had all that HBO stuff that he couldn't really do anymore because everybody
had seen it.
So now he was one,
one of the first realizations that like,
wow,
wrote this whole act for 10 years,
you know,
worked for 10 years,
honed my act,
developed this,
this killer.
That's why you don't do HPL specials.
You don't do any specialists.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Because I to know where my act
is all the time.
What does that mean?
But by that,
I mean if you want to see it,
I will come to where you are and do it.
There's nothing more annoying to me.
People say,
Hey,
I just saw so and so special and it didn't seem that funny.
I said,
where do you watch it?
I,
my iPhone.
Okay.
You know something.
Watching it on your iPhone by yourself is not going to make you laugh.
Okay.
It's not the same.
You know the difference between looking in the window of a nightclub and hearing
it and being on the other side of the window and being in the room,
that energy and gulfs you.
I mean,
it's part of it.
If you're willing to pay attention,
I'll come to where you are and I'll do it.
Okay.
I like piecemeal work,
right?
Joke,
tell joke,
get check.
That's pretty much the way my life is.
The idea.
I mean,
I remember we had a comic on the tonight show once.
He said,
oh my HBO specials brand this week.
Can you,
can you plug it?
I said,
yeah.
Okay.
He says,
and I'm going on the road.
I said,
what material are you doing on the road?
Well,
they all do a lot of stuff from the special.
I said,
you know,
it's going to be the next time.
He came back like eight months later.
He was like,
oh my God,
you were right people.
I just heard that.
I heard that crap last night because people watched the special before they come
see you,
they like you,
Oh let's watch a special then go see them and then they are so pissed that they
spent 50 bucks or whatever it is for a ticket that uh,
now they,
now they hate you.
You know,
you.
So to me,
when you do one of those specials,
you get probably a nickel of view,
maybe a penny of you.
But when you do a live on an inch,
you're making 20 bucks,
50 bucks.
But for a lot of comics,
that's how they build an audience.
They build an audience by putting together an HBO special that somebody likes
and then they write a whole new act.
And then when someone comes out to see them,
they'll see the new act that works.
But you know,
to me,
I always meet people,
say I'm writing a new hour and then I'd watch it and I go,
that's not an hour.
And that's about 16 minutes really.
Cause there's a lot of
uh Huh.
And Ah,
what else man?
How y'all doing?
Everybody good?
You all good mood tonight?
Hey,
how's that been in?
Hey man,
how you know,
that's not,
it's boom,
boom.
It's like,
it's like throwing punches
and especially old Boston style,
awesome style.
It's very attack like Lenny Clarke.
That's what I mean.
I mean,
when you get something that works you,
but you got to build that,
right?
Yeah.
But you can build it.
You can go,
you can do TV appearances,
you can do five minute bits.
You can do when people do something for a whole hour and they watch it,
boy,
that's a lot.
I mean,
you give them a taste and then you come do it in person.
I can only say what's worked for me.
I mean,
it works for me because I have jokes I wrote yesterday.
I have jokes I wrote 20 years ago and they both still work because a,
I know the last time I did this routine about,
this was 12 years ago when I was in this town.
And the idea of any of those people being in the audience tonight,
probably minimal.
You know,
if I walk on a stage,
it was just like,
I hate,
I do.
Uh,
um,
a talk show appearance and the next night I haven't been to a club.
I make sure not to do that material cause they just heard it yesterday.
Right.
So the idea that anybody can call up stuff that I did at any time,
unless you have new material every single day,
it doesn't make sense.
I had this conversation with Ari Shaffir.
It's a good buddy of mine and colleague Greg Comedian and we were talking about
it and he said that when you work on old stuff,
if you keep old stuff,
when you tighten it up or you keep,
it keeps you from expanding as an artist and,
and making stuff that's more relevant to how you think right now.
That might be something to that,
but it also keeps your famous.
It also gets to the point where people go,
well I walked in and uh,
it was a tough room in the crowd was talking and boy he got him.
You know,
again we're talking about,
I'm talking about playing hard ticket rooms where people go,
who is this guy?
What does that,
I never seen him.
When you like when you play Jersey,
when you played the Jersey shore,
you've got 70 year old guys,
you got teenagers,
you got grandmothers,
you got long shoreman,
you get sale,
you got every conceivable type of crime.
You know when you were a comedy club,
your plants essentially to the same person.
Right?
They all think alike and feel like,
I mean to me,
I mean I like when I do,
I always gear my Joe some jokes about men,
some about women.
So to me I love playing a racially and gender diverse crowd.
I hate,
it's all guys.
That's the worst I hate.
Oh what's all women?
I like it because it keeps everybody honest.
The audience polices itself,
you know,
you do a job about Amanda Juggle,
but I wouldn't do it and that's what works for me.
So to me,
I think what he's saying is probably true.
I'm just talking about making a living when you have to go somewhere and do the
job,
you know the down and dirty part of it.
Okay.
There's the fun part is show business and then there's a part where you got to
go to work.
Listen to this.
It's the b'Nai B'rith society.
They're hiring your next Wednesday,
then give me 1000 bucks.
Okay,
you've got to go there and knock that crowd out.
I mean,
that's what you gotta do.
And you think that doing special somehow or another takes away from no,
I don't think specialists or it takes away from that.
I mean,
look,
I'm just talking about me.
No,
no,
I know.
That's why I'm curious because you're one of the few guys,
one of the,
I consider you a great comment and you've been doing,
if I'm,
everybody does,
you've been doing it forever,
but there's very little of your work out there.
I think there's a showtime that I watched from,
like would you did a showtime special on?
And I get back in the day and I got that and I burned the master,
but somehow those account,
um,
but that's the opposite of what most people do.
Most people constantly want to put out new stuff.
Carlin put out a new hour every year.
Don't forget it.
See,
I was fortunate I had a platform every night on the tonight show.
I had to do 14 minutes every single night.
Okay,
so you write 14 and then it's probably 11 or 12 by the time it hits here.
So I didn't need to do special cause
I had a little tiny bit of something out every single day.
A little bit of an advertisement for people to come see it.
And so that's what worked for me.
And before I had that,
I made sure I did Merv Griffin,
Mike Douglas,
and every four to six weeks I would do let them in.
And that's how I kept it out there.
Just give them a little bit of a taste.
And when they come to your town,
they're not sticky.
Yeah,
that is interesting because you are definitely seeing a lot of people today that
are watching stand up from a youtube clip that they're watching it on their
phone and it's just not going to be the same.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not the same.
You need to experience it.
I,
you know,
live.
Yeah.
It's frustrating to me when I,
when people say they didn't think something was funny or they didn't think so,
but oh,
I watched avatar and my iPhone.
I think it was that great.
Well first of all,
it's a three d movie.
You can't watch it on your iPhone.
Stop it.
You know,
it's not supposed to be convenient.
It's comedy is supposed to be in a room that's a little uncomfortable.
It's just a little too cold.
You know all the elements that make up the ceiling.
Yeah.
We tried to do comedy in Hawaiian.
You're standing on stage and guys and sale fishes are going by and you know,
you know when the sun's out at midnight,
what are you doing?
Did you ever do stand up in a really,
really big place?
Like a giant arena?
Oh Shush.
You know,
I did the amphitheater,
I did all that stuff back in the 80s what do you think about that?
Like that seems to me like a,
you know,
they do this odd ball comedy tour now and they're doing like 20,000 seat places
and you know,
thought about it.
I was like,
man,
that seems like a lot of God damn people to do standup up for.
Very strange.
It depends what you like.
For example,
I liked doing standup so I or drive to do ten two thousand seat rooms than one
20,000 seat row.
Yeah,
I mean because I like doing it.
It's fun to do.
You know,
it's fun to tell jokes.
It's fun to see the person right there when you do those 20,000 seat things.
Okay.
If there's a light in your eye and you can hear laughs but it's,
you're not really experiencing it the same.
So it depends on,
I mean I know comics that just let him and was never comfortable in front of
live audience.
Dave was not funny as he is.
He just didn't like doing standup.
It wasn't just,
he didn't like me.
I like it.
I like reaching out and having the audience.
And that's one of the tonight show really came alive for me when I redid the
studio in,
brought the audience right up close to me so I could touch hands with people are
going to that when I have something pal,
you know,
whatever it might be.
So I like it.
I like the human contact.
You know,
standup is probably the most basic form of human communication.
There's no,
with the exception of the microphone,
that's it.
There's no trick.
There's no gimmick.
It's just humans interacting.
You know,
the other reason I like standup is people don't gather any more.
when I grew up in Andover,
once a month they would have the town meeting at the grange hall,
which is dumb.
Was that sound in North Andover?
And the whole town would show up.
Nothing ever got,
but people gathered in a room and it was fun to experience a room full of people
laughing or reacting to something.
Now everybody taxes or sits,
there's a social awkwardness of the iPhone.
But when you put people in a little room,
it's a little uncomfortable.
And he got on stage and he talked to him.
And that room is Roland with laughs.
It's really the greatest thing in the world.
It's unbelievable.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think it's an amazing art form and it's the most fun for me to watch as well
as to do.
I love,
I love watching it.
I still love sitting in the back of the saw Tom Papa last night.
He was hilarious.
He was really good at,
no,
he's so funny.
And uh,
you know,
I got to sit in the back of the room after I got off stage and watch them at the
back of the comedy store and I'm like,
yeah,
I just still love it as an art form.
I mean,
to me it's like listening to music.
You know,
I met when I first met Letterman,
I didn't really know Dave and I saw him at the comedy store and Dave had a great
way to turn a phrase.
I remember he had a,
I don't do the joke justice.
He said,
I joke about you was talking about editorials on small town TV stations and we
at w whatever are diametrically opposed to the practice of using orphans as
yardage markers on public golf courses,
something like that.
And I thought,
I just liked the way he phrased it.
To me that's like listening to a James Taylor song just to weigh all those words
come together.
You know,
when Seinfeld,
he used to have a bit about uh,
going to the dodge them cars.
It's and,
and the hopeless father and son team and I,
I like hopeless father and so I just liked the way they phrase things.
So to me,
listening to good comedy,
I can listen to it over and over.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
Uh,
I love listening to,
uh,
the way certain people phrase things and like you were saying about how you
going on stage after listening and reciting Carlin in your head,
how it sort of helped you,
like get that rhythm and cadence.
You know,
a hundred Thompson,
you should do that.
He used to write the great Gatsby,
he used to write it out.
Like,
I'll just copy the great Gatsby to sort of learn the rhythm of the words.
I think a lot of us have experienced,
uh,
going on stage and sort of feeling like you're doing someone else's cadence and
rhythm.
I caught myself once stent one time on stage at the comedy connection and I felt
like I was in the middle of doing Richard Jenny.
I was like,
I was being Richard Jenny while I was on stage.
Ooh,
like I'm kind of stealing this guys.
Oh,
he was the hilarious comic.
He's a terrific comic.
Richard.
He was one of the best that,
that people don't talk about.
He was one of those guys that sort of the guise of today maybe don't realize how
great that,
yes,
no,
he really was.
Yeah.
He was a one of the best at taking a bit and stretching it out too.
I love,
it's been on gay marriage.
You know,
this was before gay marriage is legal,
obviously,
and he used to do a bit about how great it was for gay guys.
Bob,
I'd love to marry you,
but it's against the law.
That'd be,
I used to love what he did that it used to really make you laugh.
Look,
Steve,
I'd love to,
but it's against the law.
You know,
it was the perfect excused
not to get married.
It's against the law are hilarious and he would take a bit and stretch it out
over seven,
10 minutes.
I mean,
he would find every single nook and cranny that that could be explored.
The Guy,
but sort of insecure but very funny guy.
He was troubled.
Yeah.
He was trouble like Manny,
but so disciplined.
Yeah.
Constantly working.
Constantly writing.
Numasizing fell is like that.
Very disciplined,
really rights and comes up with new stuff and you can see the difference too.
You can see the jokes come every six to nine seconds versus every 30 seconds or
some guy,
hey,
y'all good mood.
How y'all doing?
Yeah.
Woo.
That's how you get to the joke.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
That's that old school attitude to the people don't have a lot of attention.
They just,
they don't have much time for this.
Right.
Go,
go,
go.
Seinfeld's one of the few guys at rivals.
You as a car collector too.
I'm not quite,
well,
he's a Porsche guy.
He just only Porsche.
He has a thing.
He's an expert now.
He's got some German self Mercedes,
but,
but he's a real expert.
He knows his stuff.
Okay.
Yeah,
that comedians in cars getting coffee.
He's a very interesting show.
It's a great show.
It's really fun.
You know,
everybody tells you you can't do is a perfect example.
The Seinfeld show about nothing now.
No one's going to watch that biggest show of ever when he had this idea,
I would just drive around.
We just talk about whatever we want.
No,
no,
you got to have it all laid out for us.
No,
you don't.
And he proved that you didn't need to.
Well,
that's what's going on with the Internet is that you don't,
the idea that these producers and executives and directors have always had that
run networks,
that this is the only way to be entertaining.
They're wrong and it's just another way to be entertained.
But you watch,
it'll come full circle again and people go,
I'm sick of this free form stuff.
I want something a little more,
you know,
so you just,
it's just the age of living.
Most people do this show and they make it about an hour,
maybe an hour and 20 before they have to take a leak.
Yeah,
you will click.
You're about right there.
No,
I don't need to take a leak.
I thought the show was an hour.
It's as long as you want it to be.
Oh,
we can end it right now.
I've got a meeting at one,
but let's,
let's wrap it up then.
Okay.
We'll wrap it up.
Thank you very much.
Really appreciate.
Thanks for having me.
I really,
anytime you ever want to come back again,
it would be more than honored to have you call me and I'm here.
It was an honor to do your show.
I love your show.
Jay Leno's garage.
My episode is on this week with my 1965 corvette and a,
well,
it was an honor to gum and tour your facility on with the shovel and the a.
And the absolutely.
Absolutely.
Love you,
buddy.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Alright.
Ooh,
yeah.